florida congressman byron donalds and
fox nation host tommy lahren both
joining me now all right guys you know
the the the testimony or the questioning
by senator rand paul was compelling the
american people do not need the
government to tell them what the truth
is but for some reason our government
thinks that this this
nina yankowitz uh
is the perfect person according to
mayorkas who would be her boss to tell
us what the truth is what say you
congressman donald's
uh we don't need nina jankovitz we don't
need majorcas he frankly can't tell the
truth about what's actually happening on
the southern border so how can we rely
on him and his department to tell the
american people the truth about anything
this is an absolute joke but the real
issue here is that democrats have failed
across the board judge and they have to
put out narratives and talking points
and they are the ones that actually have
to use the emotions of the american
people to try to win elections because
they can't do it with facts they can't
do with debates they think nina jankovic
is going to pull them out of the fire
but they have failed broadly and
everybody knows the truth now you know
that is a good point i mean tommy they
are picking uh on emotions and and
that's what this whole thing is about
abortion but i want to stick with
mayorkis for a minute i mean that guy to
me hasn't told the truth since he showed
up i mean the border secure and you know
in a few days from title 42
drops and that you know they plan on not
listening to the federal judge
apparently they're really ready to
handle 18 000
illegals a day
listen mayorkas is way in over his head
and he should pull a gensake and maybe
just go work at msnbc or another liberal
news outlet so he can actually peddle
misinformation and disinformation but
i'll tell you this not only do we not
need the government to tell us what the
truth is if the last two years serve as
evidence everything that the government
and the liberals and government had told
us was a lie was disinformation or was a
conspiracy theory most of that has
turned out to actually be true so the
reverse is actually the case when we
look at what the government has been
peddling us for the last two years
force-feeding down our throats with big
tech on their side hopefully with elon
musk that is going to change and that's
probably why they need this woman to
tell us what the truth is because they
are terrified that the wardens of big
tech might not be refereeing for their
side anymore you know congressman
donald's tommy makes a great point and
that is we have uh former president
barack obama coming out a few weeks ago
in a speech saying you know i'm a first
amendment
speech absolutist and free speech
absolutist but we gotta have we gotta
moderate the content and then you know
within a week or two uh musk is buying
twitter and now all of a sudden we've
got this disinformation czar i mean how
far left can we possibly go to cut back
on the first amendment to the
constitution
listen the political left knows no
bounds they will do whatever it takes to
win elections to implement their agenda
nothing has changed even barack obama
when he was president he lied about
premiums he lied about what was going to
happen with obamacare i'm on obamacare
right now i've never paid more for my
health insurance my deductibles have
never been higher he was not telling the
truth yet he spends the rest of his
post-political career trying to lecture
us the political left the democrats in
congress just want to implement their
agenda they do not care who they have to
lie to they do not care what agencies
they need to create in order to get the
job done and tommy in line with that in
terms of what they need to do the doxing
of the supreme court justices of the
conservative ones who you know
apparently we don't know yet for sure
have signed on to the alito decision uh
over ruling roe versus wade and casey i
mean
it comes from the top literally
they have no problem starting with
maxine waters get in their faces how do
the american people not see this
listen the party that's supposed to be
so loving and so tolerant is anything
but and it's also a term called
gaslighting and their new czar of truth
does that very well when she says that
conservatives and republicans are the
ones that are trying to weaponize
feelings for profit weaponize feelings
for profit like maybe the death of
george floyd to raise money for blm or
every time there's a school shooting to
raise money for their anti-gun groups or
now with this latest supreme court
leaked to raise money for planned
parenthood and other entities that they
support it's called gaslighting the
democrats do it very well and
unfortunately there are so many low
information viewers and voters that buy
right on into it so it's up to us to get
the messaging better on our side that is
so true all right congressman byron
donald's tommy lahren thanks for joining
us on prime time hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else